[Applause]
[Music]
happy birthday selector radio
come closer if you want
[Music]
if you don't look right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm time for her
[Music]
when did you raise your head to fight
the flesh will snap upon your fright
the with the daylight feast in the
darkness in
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
so
[Music]
right
[Music]
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you how are you guys feeling today
good we're bringing some sun in this
next song is called games
[Music]
why don't you play why don't you play
why don't you play why don't you play
why don't you play why don't you play
why don't you play why don't you play
bless all the virgin
they will take them no matter who's
living there
they'll blame on the tribes while ones
are the tyrants and hunger of diamonds
if they tend why don't you play why
don't you play why don't you play why
don't you play why don't you play why
don't you play why don't you play why
don't you play
put your hands off for me please
[Music]
my lungs reconciled with green malachite
and with vivid smells of the market
don't break the modest harmonic g omega
you have never invented
why don't you play why don't you play
why don't you play why don't you play
why don't you play why don't you play
why don't you play why don't you play
the first day you're crying the last day
you're weeping that's why you call
holiday
remember to smile even on your way back
the line between starting and ending
why don't you play why don't you play
why don't you play why don't you play
why don't you play why don't you play
why don't you play why don't you play
[Music]
rapping
[Music]
my mom is good at rapping
[Applause]
so
um
i came here from italy and i've been
living in this country
for seven years now
um
yeah and i bring with me a bit of italy
and a bit of congo
um and i feel it would only be good to
play next a song that is in italian
because
that's a country that is dear to my
heart so hope you connect with this one
it talks about boundaries and borders
[Music]
you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we've got one more song for you
um it was a pleasure to play
um this next song is coming from my
i i'm so used to saying my next dp but
it's actually here so you can stream it
it's called on time for her thank you so
much gem supernova thank you so much
british council thank you selector radio
and happy birthday
um hope you have fun with this one it's
a good one i like it
[Music]
ha
[Music]
huh
ah
[Music]
oh
huh
[Music]
the
[Music]
i'm bringing down the moon to wake up
[Music]
just a doubt to feel slightly better if
no one in the end looks after the other
as long as they have for the trucks to
shut down and harness
[Music]
now this shame is hard to see
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
everything
[Applause]